Here's a question that seems pretty basic
and pretty simple, but it's really not quite
so straightforward.
How does an economic recession or depression
end?
In other words, we know that they happen.
And we know that eventually they end.
But what is the mechanism exactly?
We might be in a recession right now.
We could be heading into a depression right
now.
This could extend for months or years.
Some are saying to some degree we are going
to have very high unemployment for several,
several years at some point.
What we are in will end unless this is the
end of planet Earth.
How does it all end?
We know that we have a lot of self-fulfilling
prophecies that can get us into a recession.
But can those same self-fulfilling prophecies
get us out now?
This is not.
We know.
When do we.
When we say that something has ended.
This is not about the statistic that tells
us we are out of the recession or the depression.
We can argue about that.
And some people would say, well, it's based
on GDP.
GDP tells you when you're out of a recession.
What I'm talking about is not how can we tell
when we're out?
I'm talking about what is the mechanism that
gets an economy out of a recession or a depression?
Is it that we see more hiring and unemployment
goes down?
Is it that the stock market goes up and makes
people confident?
Is it just people's confidence in and of itself,
which is a cause versus an effect?
These are not simple economic questions.
And what you really need are two major things
to get out of an economic downturn.
First, the cause of the downturn needs to
be clearly resolved.
And the number two, you need a combination
of economic policy and business conditions
to start an actual recovery in terms of the
numbers.
But you also need consumer sentiment to change.
This is a reality in economies like ours that
are heavily driven by the perception of their
own state.
And that is that people fearing a recession
starting to spend less can precipitate one.
But also people feeling as though the situation
has been resolved and starting to spend more
and demand more in and of itself can help
to get us out of a recession.
So, yeah, people feeling like the recession
is over is a big part of the recession being
over and it can seem recursive or endlessly
regressive.
This is arguably not good about our economic
system.
I think it's important to understand that
so much of how we are doing as an economy
is about how people believe that we are doing.
But for now, this is our system.
And consumer sentiment is part of getting
out of a depression, because when people believe
we are out or soon to be out, they start acting
as though we are out.
Which gets us out because people start spending
and demanding goods and services.
So let's think back to 2008, OK?
The Great Recession of 2008.
Two things happened to stop that recession
and to get us out of it.
Number one, the underlying issue, which was
the fear of huge financial institutions being
insolvent as a result of the mortgage crisis
and some other reasons that was resolved,
sort of in the sense that we had some new
regulations.
We had the belief that we've put in place
new lending guidelines so the mortgage crisis
can't happen again.
We've cleaned up some corruption, supposedly,
even though nobody went to jail.
But the point is there was the belief that
the underlying cause had been resolved.
That was a big part of it.
In addition, though, we had a lot of economic
policy response under the Obama administration
that got us out.
That included that huge stimulus package that
Republicans were furious about, that Barack
Obama did.
It included new government spending.
It included some tax cuts.
So that was 2008.
The difference now with the current recession
or what some are saying is an inevitable depression
that's coming.
Related to coronavirus is that it is not a
financial institution.
Recession in principle.
What we have here is a corona virus pandemic,
which decimated demand for stuff because of
the pandemic, because of the virus, demand
for travel went down 90 95 percent.
In some cases, demand for office space collapsed.
Demand for restaurants collapsed.
All of that stuff.
So the resolution to this one is not about
government spending money or sending people
cash.
Government needs to do that as a stopgap so
that people don't starve or lose their homes
or lose their cars or lose their businesses
that they hope to go back to.
But the underlying issue here to be solved
is a medical issue.
We need treatment.
We need a vaccine.
So for now, government's role is a little
bit different in this recession than it was
in 2008.
Government needs to provide support for people
to keep them and businesses afloat in a sort
of waiting period.
It's a bridge in a sense.
Once the underlying issue, the virus is resolved,
demand in principle should start to recover.
Now it's only going to recover in proportion
to people's ability to demand things.
Now, when we say demand, we're talking about
it economically.
I can demand a private jet in the sense that
it sounds cool.
But when I talk about economic demand, it
means that there is actually the money with
which to demand these things in an economic
system.
So as people feel safe going to restaurants,
they will go to restaurants and the restaurants
will make money.
They'll pay employees.
They'll buy stuff from food supply companies.
The employees will go out and spend money
at other local businesses.
The food supply companies seeing more demand
from restaurants will start ordering more
food from producers.
And the economic activity will resume.
Traveling will, you know, then increase due
to increased air travel will mean that people
are going to be places they don't live, which
means they will demand hotel stays.
And on and on and on.
Now, a reasonable question would be.
And one that we should be asking, is there
a way to prevent these recessions in the first
place?
Now, preventing them altogether is tough.
And there's a difference between a medically
based recession like corona virus and something
like we saw in 2008, the financial crisis.
There is no doubt that we could organize economies
in a way that would soften these recessions
and make them less severe.
There are some realities about our economic
system.
There are booms and busts.
That's how capitalism works.
And we have a capitalism in the United States
that is not nearly regulated enough.
There is no incentive in systems like ours
to be proactive.
Proactive means you're spending money you
might not need to spend and you're reducing
your profits in the immediate.
That that we being proactive is not incentivized
by the system that we have.
We are reactive.
So when the boom turns to a bust, it's really
big and a ton of people suffer greatly in
the last three months.
We learned about this many systems that feel
strong, low unemployment, high stock market,
high consumer confidence looked like a very
strong infrastructure.
It was really quite fragile in about a two
week period.
It imploded.
If all along we had a more solid infrastructure,
we would suffer not nearly as much during
these downturns.
So, for example, if everybody had health care
not connected to their employer, losing a
job during a pandemic would be less of a crisis.
It would still be a crisis, but it would be
less of a crisis if health insurance was not
tied to employment.
Another example, if we had universal basic
income or something like it, jobs guarantee
whatever flavor you like, the loss of jobs
or reductions in wages would be less problematic.
It wouldn't be irrelevant, but it would be
less urgently problematic.
And the government would not be in as much
of a position of acutely having to figure
out.
We've got to start sending out checks, direct
deposits, debit, prepaid debit cards, all
this different stuff.
It would be less of a crisis.
So the lesson that hopefully we would learn
here is we can't prevent a future pandemic
from a novel virus could happen again.
It likely will happen again.
We can't prevent any up and down in the economy,
even if we ensure by putting in different
insurance policies.
There are business cycles and there are going
to be ups and downs.
But with Social Democrats like me, want is
more investment from the fruits of when things
are going well to put in place social insurance
policies that will raise the standard of living
for everybody.
Get more people off of that borderline paycheck
to paycheck situation where if you don't work
for two weeks, you now are unable to meet
your basic expenses.
Let's make the system less fragile
for
when things like this happen in the future